- Hi everyone, welcome to
the Homeroom Livestream,
Sal here from Khan Academy,
we have a very exciting guest today.
We have Tabatha Rosproy 2020
National Teacher of the Year.
So if you have questions
for what it's like
to be a teacher, especially
a teacher of early learners,
start putting them on the message boards
on Facebook and YouTube.
But before we jump into what promises
to be a really fun conversation,
I'll make my standard
announcements reminder.
The Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit organization,
we can only exist because
of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate.
Also wanna make a special shout out
to several organizations that stepped up
when they found out that we
were running at a deficit
going into COVID and that
deficit has only accelerated
because of our costs going up
because of our server costs.
We're trying to accelerate
a whole bunch of programs
for teachers, parents, and students.
So special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly and Novartis.
I still also wanna remind folks
about Homeroom with Sal, the podcast.
That's essentially a modified
version of the livestream,
kind of some of the more poignant moments
that you might find useful
and you can consume it
safely in your car wherever
without having to see things.
So I encourage you to go subscribe
to the Homeroom, the podcast.
So with that, I'm excited
to have Tabatha Rosproy on,
Tabatha, good to see you.
- Hi, good to see you
too, thanks for having me.
- No, it's my honor,
you are 2020 National Teacher of the Year,
you're based in Kansas.
So how did you become
National Teacher of the Year?
- I ask myself--
- What is the process like?
- So I was nominated at my district level
for State Teacher of the Year,
and you go to a regional banquet,
there are four regions in Kansas,
and I was named one of the
finalists here in Kansas,
and then I was named
Kansas Teacher of the Year
shortly after that, and after
that you submit an application
to CCSSO, the Council of
Chief State School Officers,
and they have a team of
17 different organizations
that pick four finalists,
and I was one of those,
I was really surprised
when I got the phone call
because it was a Washington D.C. number,
and I thought it was a political call,
just going into an election year.
So I didn't answer at first
before I got a text message
asking me to call them back.
And after that the other three
finalists who are incredible,
we all went to Washington
D.C. and interviewed
with those varying education
organizations, we did keynotes,
we interviewed with press
and just a short while later,
I was selected as National
Teacher of the Year.
- Wow, well, congratulations.
I was lucky to see some video footage
of some of the things you
do with your students.
And I didn't see what the
other teachers are doing,
but it made me pretty convinced
that you are very well deserving
of National Teacher of the Year.
I think we have some of this footage,
if we could take a look at it fully pay,
and if you could talk us
through what's going on.
- Oh yes, this is a Zoom call
with a class full of preschoolers,
which I'm sure some
people can identify with.
The older kids, you can't get to talk,
but the younger kids, you
can't get them to stop talking.
So it's incredibly unique
to be on video chat
with four year olds.
And I think at this time I
was just reading them a story
about why they couldn't be at school.
This was really shortly
after state school buildings
had been shutdown in the spring.
Oh, and this is one of our
Friday dance parties here.
- Every Friday?
- Yes, every Friday we have a dance party
and other occasionally in
between when the students
ask for them or we just need a break,
I have a disco light that
I've got pretty cheap online,
and we play oldies, we
play things that they like
from their favorite YouTube stars
and we have a great time
celebrating together.
- I hope to attend one day
this seems like a better party
than most of the things I'm invited to.
(laughing)
- Oh, and here is we were
releasing some of our butterflies.
So this is outside of the nursing home
that my preschool is housed inside of.
And what you can't see
is kind of off screen.
We have some grandma
and grandpa residents.
That's what we call the
volunteers who live there
watching us release our butterflies
that we watched grow from caterpillars.
- Wow.
- On here these are my students,
so one thing I really
focus on in my classroom
is social emotional health
and self regulation,
and those relationships
from student to student,
and here we are doing an activity
that builds those relationships,
where they're doing a row,
row, row, your boat game,
they have to keep each other
safe, it's playful, it's silly,
there's positive physical touch
and just loving interactions
and that helps them grow
closer to each other
and build those super
strong relationships.
- Wow, no, I'm, envious of your students.
I mean, I had some great teachers too,
but I don't remember the dance parties
or the row, row, row,
your boat simulations
and the butterflies.
That's incredible.
And the age group you
teach out there in Kansas,
you teach, you said preschoolers
mainly four year olds.
- Yeah I teach four year old preschool,
yeah my classroom is
funded by the public school
and special education and at-risk dollars
but yeah we're a public school
program for four year olds.
- And what kind of gravitated
you to that age group?
And what do you think
is kind of the mindset
or the special sauce that
you bring day in, day out
and I'm sure many other
teachers do as well,
but you clearly are one of those teachers
that I think these four year olds,
even when they're 40 or 50,
are gonna remember those moments.
What drew you to teaching
and especially that group
and how do you view it that gives you
that special pixie dust?
- When I was in high school,
I knew that I wanted to help people.
But I began taking the Dual
Credit College Spanish class
in which I got to go down to the preschool
on our block, like in our district
and teach Spanish to preschoolers.
And before we started
interacting with the students,
we got to just observe in the classroom.
And I remember this moment so clearly,
it was the first time I
had ever witnessed teaching
from an outsider perspective.
I had always been on the end
of being delivered instruction.
And it was the first time
that I truly saw teaching
as the art form that it is.
That teacher that I was
watching her name is Pat Walton
and she is now retired, but the way
that she connected with her students,
that she really acted as a
guide for their learning,
the way that she built
relationships with them,
it was magical for me to see.
And from then on out, I knew that I wanted
to work with kids, and
I knew that I wanted
to work with really young kids too.
- Well, that's incredible.
And there's tons of questions coming in
because I think especially--
- Okay.
- Young kid crowd...
My youngest is five and a half,
so I won't make too many of the questions
about my personal help that I need,
but from YouTube, we have a
question from Carris Alexander.
What tips do you have for older siblings
trying to help younger
siblings with tutoring
and homework in distance learning?
How much should we help and how?
- That is a great question.
I have so many students in my class
who you can tell when they haven't had
to like talk for themselves
or do things for themselves.
And usually they have older siblings.
So what I would do is
just have a conversation
with your older kids and talk to them
about the role that they play, right?
So they wanna take care of them
but the best way that we can take care
of our younger siblings,
is to help them learn
how to do things for themselves.
Because we won't always be there, right?
And they need to be able to
solve problems on their own.
And so you could give
them a list of things
that they could do to be helpful,
including being a good role model,
like what does it look
like when you are doing
your own work, include your
younger sibling in that time.
But I would just be really
open with them about that
and be thankful for the
moments that they are helping,
because you definitely
don't wanna see them
go the other way and not be
interested in that at all.
But I think for sure, older
siblings can be great models,
but you're right on that
sometimes we give them
a little bit too much help.
- So help them help themselves.
And I've gotta believe that Carris
is a pretty good older sibling.
The very fact that they're
asking this question
shows that they care a lot
so your younger siblings
are very lucky Carris.
From YouTube Miss Victoria asks,
"How do you react to sassy kids?
"The ones that say "You
can't tell me what to do",
et cetera."
I've never encountered sassy kids.
My kids never do anything like that,
but I guess in theory, other kids might.
So I'd love to be advised there too.
- I think that one of the
first things you have to do
as the adult in the situation
is recognize your triggers.
And so that definitely would
have been one of my triggers
being talked to disrespectfully
because when I was a child
that did not fly in our house,
so now I see how that triggers me
because I'm super aware of it
but what I would say is when that happens,
your child or the child
you're working with
is probably not in a state of their brain
where they can make good decisions
and be a good friend and
be kind and respectful.
So you're gonna need to help
them sort of co-regulate
in that moment.
And so that means if
you react aggressively,
they're probably gonna
react aggressively too,
because aggression begets aggression.
So what you're gonna wanna
do is to take a deep breath,
and I just say to myself,
this behavior is information, right?
And I didn't make that phrase
up, it's not unique to me.
But when we view behavior as information
and not as our students or our kids
being out to get us or
trying to push our buttons,
then we are more likely to be able
to come up with a solution that is helpful
rather than hurtful to them and to us
and to our relationship.
And so when someone says
something super sassy to me,
I might just take a deep breath
and give myself a second before I respond,
because sometimes they are looking
for a quick response from you.
But I would just say,
you can either address
that hurtful statement, I don't like it
when you talk that way to me.
If you wanna speak to me,
you can use kind words like,
and give them an example,
or I can tell you're really frustrated,
I'm gonna give you a
few minutes to calm down
and then I'll come back.
- That's powerful advice,
not just for dealing with young kids.
I would say any relationship
feelings are real,
don't escalate--
- Yeah.
- Try to understand
where they're coming from.
Just to add to that, I
mean I was joking obviously
I am always trying to navigate.
And I think I fall into
that trap as a parent does,
if like your child is
not eating or whatever,
and you're trying to push them
and then they kinda dig in their heels,
and I think they're trying to
push boundaries a little bit.
And especially if things
get really fall apart,
they're having a tantrum
or maybe you feel like having a tantrum,
how do you deal with that?
I can imagine, especially
the four year old crowd,
sometimes with my five-year-old,
he just falls apart and we're trying
to put him back toge...
How do you deal with that?
- Tantrums are a hard, right?
And my heart goes out to people
when I see their kids doing it in public,
because I know they're so embarrassed,
but what you just need to remember
is we've all been through that,
we've all gone through that,
and if people are judging
you for when that happens,
then just, you can ignore them.
But again, I would say remaining calm
is the most important
thing in that moment.
So sometimes it will look
like me asking a child,
if it's okay, if I can
hug them or hold them
or hold their hands and just
doing some deep breaths.
Because at that moment,
you can't reason with them,
so they're just different
areas of your brain,
and usually when they're
throwing a tantrum
they're in a lower center of their brain,
where they can't reason and
they're in fight or flight mode
and probably fight if
they're in that tantrum mode.
And so you would just wanna breathe,
and you calmly breathing
not engaging verbally,
usually will calm the situation enough
where you can get to a point
that you can reason with that child.
- Wow that's masterful.
I feel more empowered
just hearing you say that.
So a lot of questions
coming in from YouTube,
Hush Gotham asks,
"How do you feel when a small
kid asks a lot of questions,
"how do you deal with them?
"What to do when a kid asks a question
"and you don't know the answer back."
- So this happens to me all the time.
I always say, you never
know what you don't know
until a kid asks you to explain something.
And so like our high school mascot
where I live is the Vikings.
And someone asked me what's a Viking.
And I was like, how do I
explain this to a child?
What a Viking is.
And once someone asked me,
like, what is chocolate?
Or just something like I was like,
I really gotta go through this.
So first I would encourage
you to follow up,
and I think that it's okay to admit
that you don't know something,
so when a student asks me a question,
and I don't know, I'd be like,
let's look that up together.
Where do you think we can
find out what that is?
And so you can teach them
how to do these beginning
steps of research.
But I think also when they ask you
something that you don't know,
ask them what they think it is,
and see if you can get an
explanation from there,
kinda turn it on them and maybe start
working on some of those
critical thinking skills.
- It's interesting that
you brought up Vikings.
I recently read an article
that even our perceptions
of Vikings, we imagine
these, they're Viking
from definitely from Scandinavia,
they were the seafarers
who would go and like,
pillage coastal villages
and things like that.
But apparently the Vikings
might've been different
than we imagined, but anyway
that's a whole other topic.
- We could jus go on and on.
- Yeah it's fascinating.
One question, I mean this
is related to the last one,
but this is something I
deal with a lot at home
is I have three kids, 11, nine, and five.
You're dealing with classrooms
of many, four year olds.
one thing that kids like to do
is they like to show adults that they care
about the things that they've done,
but you know sometimes
after a long day of work
and I'm sure sometimes
you're tired at work.
You have five kids coming
at two at the same time
and say, "Hey, Ms. Rosproy
look at what I did,
look at what I did, did
you know that this is true?
Did you know that the
Vikings never ate chocolate?
Whatever, how do you deal with that?
How do you triage that inbound
that I think I see a lot
of young kids like to do.
- Oh my gosh yeah they can be exhausting.
I sometimes have bruises
on my shoulders or my legs
from being tapped so hard.
(laughing)
I did make a rule in my class.
If you want my attention,
you need to say my name
instead of tapping me as hard.
And then you just hear
your name constantly.
And I would just really try
to create some boundaries
if you know that the
minute that you get home,
that you're not gonna
be able to handle this,
you can create those
boundaries with your kids
and say all right, when I
get home, let's do hugs,
high fives, kisses,
whatever you're used to.
And then I need 10 minutes
and I'm gonna be in this room
and I'm gonna put a little
stop sign on the door,
and that means don't come in
and then do what you need to do,
to collect yourself, to
meditate, to exercise,
to check your emails, spend
a little time by yourself
because it's overwhelming,
that like fatigue
from managing a household
and managing a job.
And then I would say,
come out and be ready
to have those discussions.
And if your child is struggling with that,
I sometimes give kids a notebook
and then they can write or draw
the things they wanna talk to me about.
And then later when we have time,
I might point to my schedule and say,
"Okay, it's time to show me the ideas
that you wanted to share at circle time,
when it was everyone else's turn to talk."
So I just think creating
some routines right,
might be helpful in that situation.
- That's super valuable,
I'm gonna try to apply that.
There's a related question
from YouTube Death Stroke asks,
"What if a child asks a question
which shouldn't be answered
"at the time, like adult
stuff, what'd you do then?"
- They do, they like know
but what's funny is most of the time
they don't know that it's adult stuff.
And so, sometimes I will even
get questions in my classroom,
like about religion or about,
things that aren't really
my place to comment on,
I mean, even politics
at preschool sometimes.
And I try to be just,
you know, really neutral.
And I will say everybody
believes different things.
This is something you might wanna
ask your mom and dad about,
or your grandma about your caregiver,
whoever they live with when you get home.
And if you want me to help you do that,
let's write a note to them
and know that you brought that up.
But if it's something
kind of inappropriate,
I think that I might just say,
"Let's talk about that a little bit later
right now we're talking about math
or right now we're talking about letter A
or something like that.
I just wouldn't make a big deal about it.
Because once you make a huge deal,
the other kids know that it
was something inappropriate
and probably the pattern is gonna be,
then other kids will ask about it too.
So just try to be chill.
That would be my advice.
- Yeah now great advice.
So from YouTube, Susanna
Garcia Dominguez asks,
"Hi, Tabatha,
"how do you teach young
students to regulate?"
- Okay, this is a great question too.
So I am a huge fan of
conscious discipline.
And if you've never heard of that,
I would start by reading the book
"Easy to Love, Difficult to
Discipline" by Dr. Becky Bailey.
I'm not in any kind of like
partnership or promotion
I just love--
- Conscious discipline.
- I'm writing that down,
let me get some paper.
"Easy...
What is that again?
"Easy to Love,
- " Difficult to Discipline".
That book changed my life
and now I am a huge fan
of Dr. Becky Bailey and
all the work she does,
she has tons of free resources
on the conscious discipline website
for families and for teachers.
And one big thing to do is
first you have to teach them
sort of what feelings are, right?
What's it noticing?
What's it feel like when I'm angry?
What's it look like when I'm sad?
What is my body doing?
You wanna work on helping
them notice things
like that about themselves
and about others.
And a big way that you can do that
is not using judgemental language like,
I like it when you're mad
or like it when you're happy and calm,
I don't like it when you're sad or angry
because feelings are okay.
Like what's not okay is
exploding when you're angry.
But it is okay to be angry,
your feelings, give us information,
we just need to teach kids what to do.
We need to teach them
those replacement behaviors
for tantrums and for
throwing things or hitting
or hiding things like that.
And so again, you wanna
wait until they're calm
to do the teaching.
You wanna model calming
strategies like deep breathing,
maybe coloring a picture when
you're feeling overwhelmed
or getting a hug from
a person that you love.
I mean, I can go on and on about this,
but I think the biggest
part is letting them know
that feelings are okay
and helping them notice
what feelings look like
and what to do when you're
having those feelings.
- Really, I'm gonna buy this book
right after this conversation.
- (indistinct)
- But I love
what you're saying.
That's actually something I've
only recently appreciated,
not just with dealing with kids,
but just relationships in general
is that you should never
question someone's feelings,
feelings by definition are real.
So you should never
tell someone that like,
they're not real, or you can't have that,
or our perceptions of
reality might be different
and people can be right or wrong
about the perceptions of reality,
but the feelings are real.
And so, yeah no, I'm
definitely gonna take a look
at that book.
So this is a question
I've been getting a lot,
I'd love your advice
cause you deal day in,
day out with young kids.
From Facebook Irene is asking
with the short attention
spans that younger kids have,
how do you keep them engaged
when teaching online?
- This is so hard and I differ
a lot in my school of thought
from what the reality
that many of our schools
are in right now.
I think five to 10 minutes max
is the attention that you can keep online
as you can see it is (indistinct).
I would say the biggest thing
is to make a schedule, right?
And one of the big things
I offer to the families
of students in my class
is some kind of first
then picture schedule.
So you might have a picture
of first I'm doing Zoom.
Then I get to do a preferred
activity like playdough
or play outside, and
you can draw pictures,
you can print pictures from the internet.
If you wanna find me on social media,
I would be glad to
share with you resources
that I have already made for this.
If you wanna make your life way easier,
but just helping your kids understand
what the expectation is,
it helps them feel safe
and that helps them be
able to learn better,
be able to regulate their emotions
when it's not something that
they really feel like doing.
But also just to let them know,
hey, here's what I expect for today,
here's what you're going to do
and here's what I'm going to do.
I think that really helps
just having that routine
and the expectation set.
- Now just watching you, I mean,
you exude like positive energy,
but you seem to just have it figured out.
I'm very impressed.
There's a question here.
I don't know if you see
it at the preschool level.
I could imagine to some
degree from Facebook
Munah Yusuf is asking
how do you encourage kids
to report bullying?
I guess we could broaden that
to how you deal with bullying
I'm curious, do you see
bullying at that age group,
at the preschool level,
then how do you deal with it if you do.
- I am of the idea that bullying
is still a huge problem.
I think it's a little more invisible
than it used to be because it's become
more like cyber bullying or online,
but again, I'll go back
to conscious discipline
there's a great video out
on YouTube about like,
I think it's called "Making
a Bully from Scratch."
And it talks a lot about,
what we do as a society
that encourages that kind of behavior
and what we do and how we help
victims in that situation.
And so one huge thing we have to work on
is building relationships
between our students.
One thing that Dr. Becky Bailey also says
is that willingness comes from connection,
and so I'm a lot more likely
to wanna work with you
and get along with you if
I feel connected to you
and feel like we have something in common.
And so I think it's the job
of teachers at every level
to be building classroom
community within their school.
Like I'm doing this as intentionally,
as I am doing math and
literacy and social studies.
It is a part of every day,
it is a part of every subject
that we are looking for ways to teach kids
to see others with love and empathy.
So I think if we could do that,
at every level our kids
would be way better off,
and I think that the levels
of bullying will go way down.
- Yeah, and its a good point,
it starts from someplace
and the more you can build that early on
the resilient against bullying.
So from YouTube Newtrap Nation ask,
what do you think about
the way we are learning
during COVID-19?
And I'll expand that
question a little bit,
what are you seeing in the students?
I think your students are
very fortunate to have you
and I think you're doing
it as well as anyone can,
but are you seeing some gaps?
Are you worried about even your students
and what are your kind
of concerns more broadly
for what kids are going through right now?
- So I'm troubled by some of the things
that I see happening.
I think that teachers, administrators,
everyone is doing their absolute best,
but there are just requirements
that we have to meet from our States
and there are requirements
we have to meet federally.
I would like to see some relaxation
on some of those requirements,
because in the situation
of virtual learning,
it is never going to look
just like school does
when you're in person.
And I think the expectations
that we put on families and on students
to have kids doing this
synchronous learning experience,
six hours a day from home,
it's not sustainable,
it's not feasible and it's
burning a lot of people out.
Students and families and
teachers all included in that.
What I would like to see
is some more asynchronous opportunities.
So say teachers upload
videos of themselves teaching
or lessons or activities and
families are able to complete
those within a week's
time within the timeframe
that works for them.
- Yeah, I know what do you
say makes a ton of sense to me
I mean what we've been saying
when I'm asked the same question is
I'd argue even pre-COVID we were probably
trying to do too much, but
especially during the time
to try to transplant
six hours of in-person
with six hours of video conference.
It's gonna burn out the teachers,
it's gonna burn out the students,
It's gonna burn out the parents,
it's gonna only add anxiety.
This is the time that less is more
so that you have more space
for families to just take
care of everything else
and not atrophy.
Is it just that the teachers
are feeling pressure
from the state and I
guess then the districts
that hey I gotta cover this many standards
and this many days, and
they're saying you have to have
this much face time in person.
I think some "in person video
conference" makes sense,
but six hours is ridiculous for anybody.
- I think that what they're expecting
is kind of six hours of learning time
and so some teachers
are really able to do,
certain amount of minutes together online,
and then some of the stuff on your own.
The reality we're facing is though
that some students are home alone,
or they don't have someone
helping keep them in a routine
or older siblings or the caregiver.
And so I think some teachers
are feeling pressure
because of that to be more
present in those student lives.
But for sure, I think most of the pressure
is just coming from regulations.
And some schools just
don't have enough staff
to do anything except for let
kids do synchronous learning.
So I'm gonna be teaching in class,
if you're a remote learner,
you're gonna be watching
me teach in class.
And so that's where sort of that creates
all of that time online
that is just not healthy
and not good for kids to
just sit for six hours.
So what I hope is that we're gonna find
some more creative ways to engage online,
but I know that like the hybrid
models that are happening
are some of the most challenging.
- Hmm and we have time for
maybe one last question.
These conversations always
go faster than expected.
From Facebook, Maneeba Zeshan asks,
"How does students bond
interact with fellow classmates
"in the virtual classroom environment?
"Our kids are missing
that healthy interaction
"that they had in class
with their classmates."
- This is also tough.
I love technology in some
ways it makes our world
a lot smaller and some ways
it makes it a lot bigger.
I find the biggest most important thing
when connecting kids online,
is not just giving them FaceTime with me,
we do need that individual
face time and whole class time,
but setting up small groups
and I've seen several teachers
do this and they do
things like lunch buddies
and every day of the week
different groups of three or four students
will meet and have lunch together
then kids are more likely
and that's virtually,
kids are more likely to
open up in a smaller group,
especially our older ones
and with our younger ones,
there are a lot more likely
to be validated and heard
because they have lots of
things to share online.
And so I think that any
opportunity you have
to decrease the size of the
groups that you're working with,
you should definitely take,
because that is something that
will help build those bonds.
- No, I love that idea, we've
been throwing out the idea
instead of having 60
minutes with 20 or 30 kids,
why not have 10 minutes with
five kids with six kids.
- Yeah, yeah exactly.
- It increases--
The interactivity,
it fits into what you're talking
about around attention span, et cetera.
We're all out of time I mean,
I could keep talking to you.
And I said, I don't say so you could watch
the other films of other
people that we've...
You naturally exude this
very positive energy
that I think is part of the reason
that you much deservedly our
National Teacher of the Year
for 2020.
Do you have any just final messages
for either parents who
are especially parents
of four or five year old
struggling right now,
and teachers who are struggling
with their regular lives
and trying to do distance
learning right now.
- For teachers, the main
thing that I would say
is use your voice right now.
Okay, we have a big audience,
whether we like it or not,
for the first time, all eyes are on school
and we need you, we need the
aids, we need the custodians
and all that support professionals
to be using their voice,
to talk to the people in their district
about what their needs are and
what their student needs are.
We need you to advocate right now
and also hang in there because
you're doing your best.
And so give yourself some grace.
And that's what I wanna
say to families too.
This is a big, big, big change
in the way your lives have operated.
And so just give yourself some grace,
do the best that you can,
keep your kids on some kind
of routine and schedule,
but also give them a break
because this is hard for them
too, but just hang in there.
I always say together
we'll see it through.
And I think that's totally true.
And the more that we work
together and communicate
and advocate the better off that will be.
- Wow well, that was great advice.
I feel less anxious after you
saying that, so thank you.
Tabatha thank you so much and once again,
congratulations on being
National Teacher of the Year,
much, much deserved.
- Thank you so much for having me.
- Thank you, well, thanks everyone,
I think y'all probably felt the same,
positive energy that I felt.
It's really inspiring to talk
to a teacher like Tabatha.
Thanks so much for joining
and I will see all the
till the next conversation
is going to be next Tuesday.
We're going to have Lisa Demore
who's a New York times
columnist specializing
on kind of socio-emotional
and emotional wellbeing,
which is obviously a very important topic.
Some of which we just touched on.
So I will see you on Tuesday
on the Homeroom Livestream.
See you then.